it's like you integrating with the emr
systems of the hospital to receive all
the information about patients and
sometimes you would like to do some
changes to receive additional
information or maybe to filter out
information or to have some
clarification of the information because
it's not very formatted data not very
clear data and it's difficult because
not it's like not in the high-tech world
that you can have like immediate
response
welcome to 20-minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley in partnership with lomitek and
sponsored by homeward ventures hippo
insurance opposed hillary stanford leap
and birthright excel
welcome to 20 minute leaders today we're
going to be talking about the us health
care system meet dina fein the vice
president of r d of taylormade a
comprehensive software solution with a
mission to help patients and healthcare
providers tackle the financial
challenges of care delivery prior to
telemedicine she was vice president of r
d data collection and b2c it's similar
web she brings almost 20 years of
experience in building high performance
scalable and robust systems
she's passionate about leading high
paced r d departments setting up solid
and effective development life cycles
with a focus on technological excellence
and high standards
dina fine welcome to 20 minute leaders
vice president of r d at taylormade how
are you
i'm fine thank you michael thank you for
having me
thank you for joining me we'll dive
right into a really complicated
cumbersome but fascinating subject the
u.s healthcare system
really a complicated monster that you
know technology in the recent years is
is helping transform through startups
like taylormed and i have quite a few
friends that are working in telemedicine
so i know that i'm in good company right
now and so i'd love to hear from you a
little bit about your your understanding
of first what is the complexity that you
know that we're aware of in the u.s
healthcare system but then specifically
we'll dive into how taylormed is helping
to fix some of those issues over there
yeah
so i was actually um very unaware and
during my life about the complexity of
u.s health care i mean of course you
know from the movies that you watch
that there's a problem within challenges
and breaking bad rights he has the bills
he doesn't know how to pay for it
but it's actually so broken from the
from the root like the root system of
supporting people when they are in a
health scale problem it's just amazing
you know last year
my father was a diagnosed with a brain
cancer
and i was just you know thinking the
whole family we had all the stress of
researching about the disease and what
to do and hospitals and treatments
and
putting on above this complex situation
in the family also the concern for
financial
payment like how do you pay for this
treatment or should you choose between
living
and
maybe breaking your financial stability
of your family and leaving them without
the home or
choosing the treatment it's awful it's
awful this is one of the reasons that i
joined element from the first place
wow so a what we do here in telemed we
develop a software solution sas
for health providers to help the
patients to find the financial
assistance for their treatments for the
drugs they
should they cover on their own
and what is interesting in here that no
one
usually when he started the treatment in
the united states actually knows
what will be his um
it's called out of pocket it means what
is the patient himself will need to pay
and not his insurance okay it's very
unpredictable you don't know okay you
get to the hospital you start getting
some treatment you never know what will
be the final the final
a amount of money you should personally
pay okay now i i want to just dwell on
dwell on this point for just a second
because you know to the to the average
consumer listening to this this is
ridiculous obviously you know we're
going to be talking about thousands or
tens of thousands of dollars what is the
problem with simply knowing how much am
i going to pay for the treatment
why why is there this inefficiency and
by the way as a us you know citizen
myself having gone through this process
i too know how i didn't know how much
i'm going to be paying for whatever
treatments i got it's horrible
well because in every insurance and you
don't have some very clear format
and some standard that everyone is using
there is a lot of a little
eff
yes the letters and you don't really
know and also it's really complex it's
like some are covering just in
particular drugs and not in other drugs
and some covering doctors only in this
network and not in another network so if
you come to the hospital which supposed
to be in the network but all of a sudden
the doctor that treated you is not in
the network then you get a huge bill to
pay even that you didn't know he's out
of the network but your insurance will
just not cover it okay so it's very
complex this is just an example on on
how complex it is okay but the insurance
plan is very very complex and if you
take like an average american on the
street he will not know
what his insurance really covers and
what not all right so we know that
there's fragmentation we know that
there's lack of transparency there's
fine print there's a lot of confusion
lots of different formats which leads to
consumers not knowing how much they're
going to be spending when we're talking
about you know life-changing amounts
right so where do you fit into all of
this
problem um
so when the patient comes to the
hospital for example
and he's starting to
get some advice also from doctors and he
has his diagnosis and now he has the
treatment
and we calculate um trying to predict
his out of pocket
expenses and based on that we can flag
flag out a patients on high risk that we
need to help them in first priority okay
and then the hospital
employers
will attend this patient on first
priority uh
using our system okay so we also giving
a length in this high risk patient
and we're also building a plan how we
can help this patient
okay so so so and that's solving an
additional problem correct
um
yes you are when you know that someone
has out i mean if you don't have a very
high out of pocket you probably don't
need our help right you will handle on
your own because you have insurance and
different
other solutions but once a patient have
a very high out of pocket he needs help
so what we do now in united states
apparently there is like thousands
thousands tens of thousands of different
assistant programs all over the place
and no one single place that you can
access this information and to
understand
uh what is the system program you are
eligible for
and what is not so
um there is as i said there is a lot a
lot a lot of different assistance
programs in the united states and no
single place
to find all of it so what we're doing
telemet in addition to the prediction of
out of pocket and different suggestions
uh for the patient you're going and
searching
um the internet different sites a
pharmacist
um government plans federal plans uh
private funds
um and we have all of this like a
programs in hand okay due to this
activity
and then automatically
we
search for every patient in the system
research what are the system programs
that he is eligible for and there are
very different criteria for this a
assistant program sometimes it's income
what is your insurance type
where you live
and what disease you have and what
treatment you should get and we do it
all in automatic way
and
also in addition these assistant
programs they are very
dynamic it means that one day you have a
funding for some assistance program but
a lot of people already applied and it's
finished so now it's closed and we need
to wait till this system program will be
opened again and once it opened we send
a lot of notification and a length to
the hospital say
so they know that for this particular
a disease this particular patient the
fund is open now please apply now for
them please help them now because maybe
a half day later it will be too late and
will be closed okay so it's a very
dynamic world of assistance programs and
different kinds that we sell the
matching between the patients and
the programs and we can help them like
real time
now
you know obviously one of the most
complicated parts about this whole
system is the is is how fragmented the
supply chain is the different
stakeholders the different incentives
so you're you're helping obviously the
customers the patients
how does this how do how do the
different stakeholders react to this and
where where is taylormad actually living
in in the whole system is it integrating
it with the with the hospitals with the
healthcare providers do the cut do the
patients come and and and use the the
software how does it actually work
yes we integrate with the health
providers because there is a need that
there are two needs that we need
to answer first one and this is our real
mission as telemed is to help patients
okay
but the second one is the very
a big problem of american hospitals
because they are private hospitals and
if they give care and they must give
care of course that everyone that is
coming to the hospital they receive
receive help but if the patient cannot
pay
hospital has a problem because he
provided service which will be unpaid
and
it may lead it to loss of revenues and
even to bankruptcy
right that makes a lot of sense and so
tell me a little bit about you know the
the the life cycle of taylormade and
what perhaps you learned from working
with hospitals working with healthcare
providers because i think that's really
you know there's a lot of insights to be
learned from just interacting with such
complicated organizations
well yes
the hospitals say i think that um
what character the hospital is it's like
a bit of heavy organizations
and itc stems and administration on the
i.t system it's not
a very easy to move to make changes and
this is one of our challenges it's like
you integrating with the emr systems of
the hospital to receive all the
information about patients and sometimes
you would like to do some changes to
receive additional information or maybe
to filter out information or to have
some clarification of the information
because it's not very formatted data not
very clear data and it's difficult
because not it's like not in the
high-tech world that you can have like
immediate response sometimes you think
it can take months
to move like the integration technical
project
but
from the administration a perspective of
the hospital itself that's working with
our system they are very happy that they
have this opportunity automatically to
help patients because they are trying to
help them but it's like manual process
which is very very slow
and using our system it can actually
scale
the ability to help much more patients
right you know that makes a lot of sense
now what what is the
you know why is this a good time to do
this so in other words why
you know what what where is the
technology coming into play here that
perhaps a few years ago or more than
that you know it wasn't this this is
something that wasn't really able to be
done
well i think it's ability to work with a
lot of data
and the ability on our perspective the
ability to work in the cloud to be sas
organization because if we needed to
deploy some
devices or local on-prem
solutions it's very very hard with
hospitals and with the organization as i
described before so bank sas in the
cloud web application that
the hospital
administration can just log in and start
working on the system it's amazing
progress that we didn't have like 10
years ago maybe so easily
right
and of course
such big data it's like we have
hospitals with
a
hundred thousands of patients and we we
pull all of this data like nightly and
we process this data and the
er er producing insights on this data
like daily this is an amazing progress
in which technology allows us to do
right and so as vice president of
research and development
how do you go about thinking
you know the
how to leverage technology really and r
d
to really make
make the biggest impact here what where
do you see your role in the strategy
of taylormed
um
well i would like to take this system to
be much more sophisticated and be
starting to do so i would like to
involve much more a machine learning
artificial intelligence in predicting
out of pocket and predicting high risk
patient or even much
more practical
problems tactical problems like how do
you map all of this data from the
hospital to formatted data because it's
not like very formatted and this is i
think this is our direction now to make
the system much more sophisticated and
smart
and so as you're navigating within
taylormad um and you know you're working
with the leadership team to
to work on the strategy and how to then
continuously work with the different
stakeholders
how does the r d fit into the discussion
about the strategy of where taylormade
is headed next how much of that is being
guided
by r d versus the incentives of the
stakeholders because here we're talking
again about a a very special ecosystem
that is very very complicated regulated
and and has a lot of different
incentives
yes i think that when working with the
stakeholders i mean especially in
startups it's usually the matter of
balance because
um there is a lot of urgencies when you
work in startup and a lot of different
requests from different customers that
you really would like to keep them happy
and this is a versus the the long-term
solution that i just described such as
how do you invest rest of says in such
long-term solution like a.i because it
doesn't have like one month to develop
this feature you need to invest in it
and to research and to bring a
specialist
and this is this is a bit tricky but i
think this organization as a leadership
um
we all in the leadership team understand
what is it that we want to achieve the
next year
and how we get to it and this is the rnd
responsibility to push for long term
solutions and not only solving crisis
and that makes a lot of sense and uh you
know obviously that there's a there's a
llama whether we can talk about whether
it's the health care system
or or taylormade specifically or your
work
but but i i have a few more questions
about you dina and i want to get to know
you a little bit better and i want you
to take me back to even your childhood
what really fascinated you as a kid you
know before perhaps you you were an
engineer and what really fascinated you
in your day-to-day
well first of all i'm originally i was
born in
russia siberia
and it was a very a tough place to grow
in
and it's a most of the time it's a
winter and very cold like minus 35 is
the average a temperature and they um i
think that one of the first thing that
really fascinated me that it's like
every october we had the fell snow after
the summer a period
and um
the flakes you had this huge flakes of
snow falling down from the sky and as a
kid i was really fascinated about it wow
what was it about the flakes that
fascinated you
the structure i just couldn't you know
it's perfect and you just look at it and
you
fascinate how it was created in such a
beautiful way
very very cool i love i love that
fascination and what inspires you today
as you go about your day-to-day whether
it's within taylormade or elsewhere
well in telomere actually it's very easy
because there is such a huge impact on
patient lives and we even measure
ourselves like on daily basis our kpi
that we like display everywhere in the
company is the number of patients today
we got helpful for them okay and it's
really inspiring you see this number
like five more 10 more 100 more and it
gives a huge
sense of satisfaction
and so these are clients that you
actually were able to match
with
some with with some
organizations that can help finance or
help them know
it's actually already approved the
system not only the matching because
when you once you match you also need to
enroll the application and to wait you
know to if there's some process of
enrollment and approval of the
application this is like what is
approved already it means that the
patient got help
okay very very cool and so that is that
is that something that is being
displayed to all of the employees that
everybody can see yeah
we have it on the monitors in the
company
very very cool and dina what are three
words that you would use to describe
yourself
well um yeah i'd say it's a tough one
um i think it's a
probably am
strong-minded i'm very curious
fun
and blonde i guess
wonderful dina thank you very very much
toda thank you for the great work and
thank you for sharing the time with me
and this is great stay safe and stay
healthy
thank you mike